What’s up, guys? Michael here. I have a
question: When’s the last time you went
to the movies specifically to see a comedy?
What about a rom com? If you’re like most
Americans, it’s probably been a minute.
People in general are skipping out on your
classic funny-bone-tickling films, and comedies
that succeed at the box office are becoming
the exception rather than the rule. We’re
seeing lots of comedies flounder this year,
from Booksmart to The Beach Bum to The Long
Shot to Late Night and on and on and on. Even
Men in Black: International only pulled in
250 million, a pale comparison to the 624
million its predecessor Men in Black 3 made.
Indeed, you could almost hear the industry
breathe a collective sigh of relief when the
recent comedy Good Boys hit 21 million in
its opening weekend, making it one of only
two comedies to hit #1 in the box office this
year. Comscore media analyst Paul Dergarabedian
summed up the situation, saying, “This is
like a unicorn sighting.” Even so, 21 million
is a sum that probably wouldn’t have even
made us blink circa the summer of 2009, when
the The Hangover pulled in a cool 45 million
during its opening weekend.
If you scan a list of top performing films
of the late 90s, or even the early to mid
aughts, a whole lot of them are comedies.
What happened to the days when Austin Powers
ruled the box office? Where’s our 2019 Pretty
Woman? And, just for argument’s sake, why
no Hangover IV? The truth is traditional film
subgenres like the rom com or those gross
out comedies of the 1990s seem about as culturally
relevant as a late night sockhop at a high
school gymnasium.
But before you grab that comedy-shaped casket
from your closet, let’s look a little closer.
Is comedy really dead? What if it never even
existed in the first place? Let’s find out
in this Wisecrack Edition on the maybe death
of comedy?
We think a quick recap of the current comedy
landscape is in order. News outlets like The
Hollywood Reporter have made a habit of sounding
the alarm about the death of comedy films.
We’re treated to ever more dire statistics
showing comedic box office flops, And we’re
seeing fewer laugh out loud comedies Total
box office revenue for comedies shrank from
2.5 billion in 2009 to just 1 billion in 2018.
In 2018, comedies accounted for just 7.2%
of all domestic box office revenue.
So what made traditional comedy films an endangered
species? You the easy answer might be the
ever-proliferating streaming services, but
the answer is a little more complicated. Also,
it involves China.
As you, a presumable human being watching
YouTube, certainly know, consumers have more
entertainment options than ever before. You
can stream anything your heart desires on
10 different competing platforms or watch
your bestie eat tide pods on YouTube. Note
that these alternatives are typically cheaper
than a movie ticket.
And how does a studio deal with the competition
from all these sick TikTok compilations? They’re
going international, or at least, MORE international.
Studios are coping with domestic losses by
trying to maximize their profits in places
like China, Japan, India and France. Indeed,
in 2018, Warner Brothers earned just $1.9
billion dollars in North America, compared
to a hefty 3.6 billion dollars overseas. Across
the board, international audiences are booming,
and the Motion Picture Association of America
predicts that China will soon overtake the
US as the largest movie market in the world..
But how does one make an American film with
widespread international appeal? It’s not
necessarily Meg Ryan really enjoying this
sandwich. “I’ll have what she’s having.”
Instead, it’s usually fast cars, big guns,
and a superhero or two or three… or ten.
Indeed, comic book films and action flicks
are a perfect fit for the international audience,
as they peddle largely in special effects
that can be appreciated regardless of your
language or culture. As non-dialogue heavy
films, they also require less pesky dubbing
or subtitles, while offering the universal
appeal of watching shit blow up.
In contrast, comedies are NOT as easy to port
over to a Bangladeshi theatre screen. That’s
because comedies rely a lot on cultural specificity.
Just think of how different the British Office
is from its American counterpart. Or, how
the show also spawned iterations in places
like India, Chile, and Finland - all with
their own cultural quirks. If you’re still
thinking comedy can transcend international
borders no problem, peep this 1996 Chinese
comedy God of Cookery. If you’re not from
China - is this funny to you? Probably not.
The Rock breaking out of a cast with his bicep
might be universal, but it’s hard to make
a comedy that really appeals to the international
masses. Thus, studios aren’t really investing
in developing new comedy scripts the way they
used to.
Judd Apatow, the literal creator of the modern
Ford assembly line of comedies, echoes this
argument, telling Indiewire that comedy film
basically died after the last writer’s strike,
which ended in 2008. Apatow says “I feel
like the studios don’t buy as many scripts
now…. As a result, a lot of great comedy
writers are going to television instead…”
So there you have it, our investigation comes
to a close. Say goodbye to all your favorite
forms of comedy, from star vehicles for people
like Will Ferrell and Meg Ryan to quality
parodies like Scary Movie to delightful gross
out comedies like There’s Something About
Mary. Instead, if you feel like laughing,
looks like you’re going to have to stick
to TikTok.
But wait… what about this? “As far as
I’m concerned, that’s America’s ass”
That line brought the house down. Or take
this moment from Get Out “I’m TS mother***ing
A, we handle sh*t” That’s genuinely funny,
right? Indeed, comedian Jordan Peele’s seamless
transition into the horror genre hasn’t
stopped him from showcasing his sense of humor.
Even though we’re buying a ticket to see
a horror film, we also walk in pretty sure
that something’s going to make us laugh.
“By the way I would’ve voted for Obama
for a third term if I could.” Has comedy
just undergone some kind of metamorphosis?
To understand the cosmic forces at play in
a Marvel movie like Endgame or a horror
film like Get Out, we’ll need to take a
look at film scholar Geoff King. In his
book Film Comedy, King basically says that
the term “comedy” can’t be fully understood
as just a genre, arguing that it is “so
widespread as to be difficult to locate as
a single or stable generic… form.” Instead,
he suggests looking at comedy as a mode. But...what’s
a mode - and how is it different than a genre?
Simply put, a genre is a category of film.
Take, for example, the Western. Nearly all
films within a genre will share certain essential
narratives, characters, or other features,
like setting. Westerns typically have a rugged
cowboy, an expansive dusty American landscape,
an aesthetically unappealing villain and some
form of a gun fight. Both the classic High
Noon and the unclassic Wild Wild West share
these features and thus, both are westerns.
In contrast, a mode is a “manner of presentation.”
It’s a mood or feeling, and all the choices
that contribute to that mood. It’s helpful
here to think of how mode works in music.
A musical mode is a scale with specific notes
and melodic features. Take the Dorian mode,
made up of these notes arranged in this manner.
Both the traditional hymn “Drunken Sailor”
and the Latin Jazz songs “Oye Como Va”
are written in the Dorian mode, though the
two songs belong to radically different genres.
Similarly, in film, both Shazam and Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood use a comedic mode, though
the former is also a superhero flick and the
latter is also a thriller and a drama. Got
it? So, King’s argument goes, because “any
genre may be treated as a subject for comedy,'
it's more accurate to see it as a mode, a
modifier of other genres rather than simply
one in its own right.
While Film Comedy was published back in 2002,
we’d argue that King’s point offers a
lens to look at comedy that is even more relevant
today. Fewer comedy movies are made than ever
before, and the ones that are made fail at
the box office. But we might still LAUGH at
the movies just as much. So, King’s diagnosis
of comedy as more of a mode than a genre rings
truer than ever before. But how exactly does
this “mode” of comedy manifest in movies?
At first glance, that seems simple: Comedy’s
what makes you laugh. But what if, say, in
the cinematic masterpiece The Room, the filmmaker
wasn’t trying to make you laugh? And what
if a comedy film like Bad Santa doesn’t
make you laugh, even though it’s trying
to? It’s more complicated than just eliciting
a laugh - it needs to be intentional. King
expands his definition of comedy in film as
a mode that “tends to involve departures
from… what are considered to be the normal
routines of life of the social group in question.”
Take a normal situation - You’re at the
grocery store. Thenadd a departure from
your norm - You’re wearing a bathrobe and
sandals and have to write a check for $0.69
- Tada! You have comedy.
The form of comedy can vary, it can result
from incongruity - like a superhero hanging
out in a convenience store. Or it can result
from exaggeration, like the Dad’s over-the-top
attempt to sound like a tough guy in Us: “So
if y’all wanna get crazy, we can get crazy.”
Ultimately, King says, comedy results “from
a sense of things being out of place, mixed
up or not quite right.”
Furthermore, modality isn’t just in the
tone of the words being spoken or images being
shown. King notes that modality can be “complex
and multi-dimensional”, and include elements
like the use of music, sound, or opening sequences.
For instance, we can see how music is used
when Alison Williams’s character hilariously
drinks a glass of milk segregated from a bowl
of fruit loops while listening to the song
"(I've Had) The Time of My Life.” Both sound
and even the use of color are funny in context.
The cheery tune calls attention to the incongruity
of a diabolical character drinking a wholesome
glass of milk while literally looking for
the next mark for her parent’s weirdo gang
of brain-swapping yuppies. At the same time,
the flat-out bizarre method of cereal consumption
defies common sense. Seriously - she doesn’t
even eat an entire fruit loop in one bite.
Or let’s look at how characters, narrative
and tone can combine to create a comedic mode.
Take the opening scenes of last year’s Halloween
reboot, in which a couple of true crime podcasters
attempt to interview Michael Myers. The whole
sequence is full of self-aware commentary
on true crime culture and the commodification
of popular criminal personalities. “We’re…
we’re making a podcast.” “We’re investigative
journalists!” This scene feels decidedly
more comedic than anything we saw in the film’s
1978 predecessor. You can see the modality
of comedy working its way in, even as the
film prepares us for lots of bloodshed.
And, of course, we can’t talk about modern
comedy without dealing with Marvel, which
has basically turned the superhero film into
a debatably knee-slapping comedic experience
with silly one liners, absurdist situations,
and all the self-aware humor you could want.
Now one caveat - We think it’s reasonable
to assume that, in simpler times of filmmaking,
it would have made more sense to view comedy
as a genre. That’s because before the late
1950s, films typically conformed pretty neatly
into defined categories, and were less likely
to borrow from one another. It was unlikely
that you would see a sci-fi - drama like Arrival
or a funny drama like Juno. As a result, comedy
may have acted more like a consistent genre
and less like a mode. But today, we’re seeing
genres becoming increasingly more unstable.
Indeed, films today are more likely to take
a buffet style approach to genre. Oftentimes,
these are used to appeal to more media-savvy
audiences who have come to recognize tropes
in a more conscious way. As this happens,
we see comedy becoming almost like ambient
background music.
Once we start thinking of comedy as mode rather
than a genre, it becomes clear that our comic
sensibilities are not only alive, but perhaps
even thriving. With the world an ever-larger
dumpster fire, maybe we’re more in need
of a laugh than ever - even if we’re not
seeking it in the form of a washed up newscaster
and his accidental profanity “Go f**k yourself
San Diego”
And of course, if you’re looking for a laugh,
just turn on the TV, where comedy is more
than alive and well in the form of It’s
Always Sunny in Philadelphia, South Park,
Rick and Morty, Bojack Horseman, Silicon
Valley and on and on and on. Even still,
we’d say comedy is also surviving on the
big screen as a mode, and if you agree with
King, that’s all it ever was in the first
place.
So what do you guys think? Is comedy in film
deader than Uncle Ben after another Spiderman
reboot, or totally alive and well in unexpected
ways? Are you digging Jordan Peele’s brave
new world of horror comedies or do you miss
the days of Tom Cruise running a brothel in
Risky Business?? Let us know in the comments.
And a big thanks to all our dope patrons who
support the channel and our podcasts. Don’t
forget to hit that subscribe button -